alors on va continuer on peut en venir
maintenant philippe mangin philippe
mangin c'est le président du groupe
invivo c'est d'abord un agriculteur
céréalier dans la meuse et et une vive
hausse et un grand groupe agricole de
l'agro industrie agroalimentaire un
groupe de cinq milliards d'euros qui
maintenant va passer à 10 avec un rachat
récent mais les actionnaires se sont pas
des gens qui ont un portefeuille en
bourse ses actionnaires ce sont les
paysans sont les agriculteurs parce que
in vivo c'est une union de coopératives
et c'est aussi en cela qu'il était
intéressant pour nous d'accueillir
philippe mangin parce que c'est de
montrer aussi ce que les agriculteurs
sont capables de réussir de faire de
peser sur le marché international et
puis de construire de véritables outils
économiques avec leur engagement et leur
et leur financement parce qu'un groupe
de cette taille là mais il appartient
aux agriculteurs il n'existe que parce
que les agriculteurs ils sont en ayant
investi lors des parts sociales philippe
je te laisse peut être réagir sur nos
propositions et puis après même sujet un
débat merci christian je suis très
heureux de participer à ces débats d'une
grande qualité
ça fait du bien et très heureux aussi de
d'observer d'avoir parcouru et toutes
vos propositions que je trouve très
riche très dense très à propos je
reviendrai sur quelques-unes d'entre
elles je voulais auparavant en quelques
minutes peut-être tenter de délivrer
deux ou trois messages beaucoup de
choses ont été dites ça me permettra
peut-être de d'accentuer certains propos
temps évoquée par par christiane lambert
que par michel edouard leclerc
avant je voudrais dire que il me semble
qu'il y a urgence à ce que l'agriculture
réintègre les logiciels politique
il ya vraiment urgence et ce n'est plus
cas depuis quelques années
malheureusement le traitement de
l'agriculture n'est pas à la hauteur
l'agriculture c'est l'alimentation c'est
la santé alors certes cette crise vient
de nous le rappeler
j'ai la nature c'est la nature celle
vivant c'est l'aménagement du territoire
et puis l'agriculture c'est aussi un
enjeu géopolitique 1 elle donc un
élément de stabilité et de paix dans le
monde nous frisons là un prix des
céréales qui peut déclencher des émeutes
dans les pays les plus pauvres
rapidement donc c'est tout ça
l'agriculture et c'est pas possible que
ça ait disparu comme ça a été le cas des
grandes priorités de la nation c'est pas
possible que nous n'ayons pas un grand
ministère qui soit vraiment en mesure de
placer l'agriculture face à toutes ces
missions à tous et à tous à tous ces
enjeux
j'irai même que ce que l'agriculture
subit depuis quelques années je dis bien
subi et inadmissible dans un pays comme
la france la france agricole a tout pour
réussir
mais vraiment tout invivo est présent
dans 19 pays
ça m'amène donc un peu à part courir
aller dans ces pays où nous sommes
présents et dans d'autres encore partout
partout l'agriculture française et salue
tous ceux qui sont venus la visiter n'en
reviennent pas de sa qualité de sa
performance de son organisation etc
il n'y a pas un pays dans lequel on ne
nous invite pas à venir nous installer
il n'y a pas un pays qui ne réclame pas
une jv un partenariat pour qu on apporte
notre savoir faire et ses notes dit
notre diversité
ça a été évoqué elle n'a pas
d'équivalent il y a
un pays qui peut offrir un dans un
panier de denrées alimentaires aussi
riche que celui de la france
nous le mentionnons tout à l'heure il
nous manque le café le cacao un peu
d'agrumes et encore et encore mais on a
tous on a tous et au lieu de s'en
réjouir
au lieu de s'en réjouir au lieu d'en
faire un fleuron de notre économie
un secteur stratégique au niveau mondial
on vient de parler d'airbus mais on
devrait traiter nous français la
question l'école avec la même force la
même ambition la même légitimité que le
secteur de l'aéronautique
au lieu de cela on a au contraire
installé dans la société le doute les
peurs notre société s'est interrogé sur
la qualité de notre agriculture de notre
alimentation pour sa santé sur les
effets nuisibles pour l'environnement et
même sur la nécessité qu'elle participe
au défi mondial qui nous est lancé au
défi alimentaire
moi j'ai entendu récemment encore des
ministres d'hier à quoi bon
l'exportation
sommes nous suffisamment compétitifs
pour rivaliser avec les russes sur la
mer noire etc on en est arrivé là alors
que la performance de notre agriculture
est remarquable et saluée par tous alors
moi je dis je reprend d'ailleurs une
expression du duc du club déméter et de
sons de son directeur sébastien biz qui
préface est le dernier numéro annuel du
club déméter il dit ceci nous courons le
risque d'une vision de l'agriculture en
3d d comme décroissance des comme
démondialisation d comme désunion et
bien je trouve que ce risque est
effectivement bien présent et que c'est
la raison pour laquelle il faut que les
vous vous en parler de ces questions
comme vous vous êtes en train de le
faire en ce moment et que vraiment la
question agricole redevienne une autre
question politique a une vie vaut quand
même que je parle un peu de notre groupe
et de ce qu'on y fait avec nos 200
coopératives à dire adhérentes
on essaie de cultiver josé une grande
ambition pour cette agriculture
française dans deux directions
d'abord en tentant d'améliorer le
rayonnement de la culture française dans
le monde
et pour ça il faut mieux répondre aux
attentes des pays importateurs et dans
nos secteurs celui des céréales et des
vins maintenant je vous assure qu'on
travaille beaucoup là-dessus parce que
on n'a pas non plus suffisamment écouté
les pays importateurs dans leurs besoins
et c'est aussi parfois pour ces raisons
que nous perdions des parts de marché
donc améliorer le rayonnement de la
culture française dans le monde et
considérons que c'est une vraie mission
de toute la profession mais
particulièrement d'un groupe comme cette
comédie à l'ambition d'initier d'inciter
d'accompagner la nécessaire
transformation de l'agriculture
bien sûr que l'agriculture est en cours
de transformation
bien sûr qu'elle doit se transformer
transformation que les consommateurs
souhaitent lors sa tante leur demande le
révèle chaque jour un peu plus
transformation que les citoyens exigent
en matière d'environnement et j'allais
dire surtout transformation que le
changement climatique impose tout
simplement tout simplement donc
l'agriculture doivent effectivement se
transformer pour suivre cette
transformation dans laquelle elle est
engagée et elle a tous les atouts pour y
parvenir
j'allais cette ambition cet exercice qui
nous qui nous anime qui nous motive
il vise aussi à ce que nous essayons de
sortir de cette opposition imbéciles
dans laquelle certains voudraient nous
enfermer
position entre l'agriculture dite
conventionnelle je crois que c'est le
monde doit être banni du vocabulaire
conventionnelle ça voudrait dire que la
culture n'a pas bougé depuis 40 ans
alors qu'elle elle étant remises en
cause permanentes en tout cas opposition
dans laquelle on veut nous enfermer
entre une agriculture dite
conventionnelle et l'agriculture
biologique
pour ce faire nous arriver vous redis il
faut inventer une nouvelle agriculture
l'agriculture de la troisième voie c'est
quoi cette nouvelle agriculture
c'est une agriculture qui sera
prometteuse d'une totale protection des
ressources naturelles sol air eau
j'ajouterai même biodiversité c'est
possible c'est possible c'est une
agriculture qui sera prometteuse 2-0
résidus de pesticides dans les produits
agricoles et alimentaires
c'est possible certains agriculteurs
fournisseurs par exemple du groupe
bonduelle sont aujourd'hui capables de
tenir cette promesse
donc cette agriculture de la troisième
voie nous la mettons en place non pas en
ayant recours aux méthodes du passé
on est content qu'un ministre
l'agriculture il ya deux ans sur les
terres d'angoulême je crois disait il
faut que l'agriculture reviennent aux
méthodes de nos grands pères s'est il
prononcé par un ministre l'agriculture
il ya deux ans mais c'est fou c'est fou
c'est pas justement en ayant recours au
passé mais à l'immense champ
d'innovation qui est en train de
s'offrir à nous immense champ
d'innovation nous allons en effet
connaître une révolution technologique
en agriculture aussi importante que
celle d'après guerre avec le plan
marshall et l'arrivée des premiers
tracteurs c'est une révolution au moins
aussi importante qui nous attend avec
l'arrivée des nouvelles technologies
des capteurs dans les sols pour parfaire
les connaissances agronomique
bactériologiques et c'est jusqu'à
l'informatique embarquée dans les
matériels
champ à l'assiette il y aura
digitalisation de l'agriculture avec des
miracles avec des miracles et les choses
ne sont plus aujourd'hui dans les
laboratoires il sonde en est au stade de
la recherche appliquée et savas
vulgariser voilà donc comment nous
allons pouvoir produire plus la
démographie mondiale nous le commande et
produire mieux en donnant même en
devenant même une solution pour le
changement climatique
nous en parlions l'autre jour christian
je me disais l'agriculture sera une
solution
moi j'en suis vraiment content vraiment
convaincu alors c'est une transformation
qui suppose un petit moulin un vaste
programme d'investissement de
l'agriculture et des agriculteurs
investissements qui devront être
accompagnés je me tourne vers anne moi
j'aurais rêvé que le deuxième pilier
soit plus ambitieux pour accompagner
l'investissement mais il faut qu'on se
mobilise et je crois qu'il faut qu'on se
mobilise aussi sûr d'une façon générale
le financement de l'agriculture
comparable à l'industrie lourde
fortement consommatrices de capitaux
et je pense que les prêts bancaires ne
suffiront pas à accompagner cette
transformation a accompagné tout le défi
du renouvellement des générations
je pense qu'il faut qu'on réfléchisse à
d'autres méthodes de financement on y
travaille chez christiana quelques-uns
autour de la chair fine agri notamment
et de philippe dessertine
on constate que les fonds financiers
sont à la recherche d'investissements
mais à condition que nos projets soient
de couleur verte ces propos pour faire
simple si nous avons cette possibilité
de leur promettre les vertus
environnementales de nos projets alors
ils sont prêts à déployer des milliards
pour l'agriculture
on le constate un conte les réflexions
que nous conduisons
enfin un petit mot aussi parce que dans
d'autres responsabilités je suis en
charge de la bioéconomie et c'est un
sujet qui me qui me passionne je
voudrais vous dire combien l'agriculture
va apporter de réponse à la stratégie de
défaut si lisa sion de notre économie
c'est là aussi un chant incroyable en
développant l'agriculture dite de
convaincre de conservation que vous
préconisez d'ailleurs à juste titre on
va encore augmenter la disponibilité des
bio ressources déjà considérable alors
les bioénergies biogaz bio gnv bio
carburant hydrogène vers les
biomatériaux les bioraffineries en tous
genres qui sont en train de de pousser
dans ma région autour de reims de
carling de fessenheim maintenant c'est
inimaginable si on sait accompagner
toutes les start up qui travaille sur
ces sujets mais vraiment il ya un champ
de développement extraordinaire
tout ça ça va offrir d'incroyables
perspectives aux agriculteurs et des
compléments de revenus non négligeable
et qui peuvent d'ailleurs stabiliser une
partie du revenu parce que quand on vend
des bioénergies souvent c'est une
politique contractuelle longue et c est
ça apporte un complément stable dans le
revenu des agriculteurs ce qui est
vraiment apprécié enfin et je ne veux
pas être plus longs pour conclure je
voudrais vous remercier d'avoir placé la
compétitivité au coeur de vos travaux
thématiques vraiment abandonnés et avec
toutes les conséquences qui ont été
évoquées dans nos échanges
le revenu agricole c'est d'abord la
différence entre le produit de ventes et
les coûts de production c'est ça le
revenu bon le produit de vente
on vient d'en parler d'abord nous
l'offrons sur un marché concurrentiel
c'est ainsi et on peut espérer conquérir
plus de valeur notamment dans la
différenciation mon produit apporte un
plus
alors il ya
des tas de deux critères qui peuvent
être considérés mais en tout cas bon le
coût de production
le coût de production moi j'ai envie de
vous dire on en a sous le pied
vraiment côté pouvoirs publics
évidemment avec vous l'avez dit déçu
réglementation des sur normes et une
fiscalité toujours pas adaptées au monde
agricole d'aujourd'hui vous le dire faut
le dire y compris pour la transmission
etc
donc oui il faut travailler sur les
facteurs de compétitivité et c'est
vraiment important que vous ayez placer
cette thématique ou au coeur de vos
travaux
l'agriculture française doit fournir
l'alimentation de toutes les bourses
vraiment faut jamais oublier ça la
montée en gamme bien sûr le grand
discours du président de la république à
rungis pour lancer les les états
généraux de l'alimentation il faut
monter en gamme wave on est très bien
trois fois oui mais enfin bon pour une
partie de la consommation pour une
partie de la consommation
enfin celle que nous consommons tous les
jours entre deux réunions à midi sur le
pouce la restauration rapide eux les
relais et puis et puis les budgets des
ménages donc viser le seul objectif de
la montée en gamme
c'est ouvrir au grand large les portes
des importations et c'est donc bien ce
qui s'est passé ces dernières années
avec l'effritement permanent de notre
balance commerciale y compris dans des
secteurs où c'est inadmissible importée
50% de nos volailles ce n'est pas on
vise ne sais pas c'est incroyable tout
simplement tout simplement
donc bien sûr qu'il faut travailler sur
la compétitivité pour satisfaire tous
les besoins de nos ménages y y compris
les plus fragiles moi je je vis dans un
petit village il ya des familles qui ont
deux salaires un peu plus élevé que le
smic
ils ont trois enfants qui
qui poursuivent leurs études en faculté
etc je vous assure que quand ils vont au
leclerc à verdun ils ont une liste de
courses et ils font bien attention à ne
pas dépasser le budget qui sont fixés
alors faut quand on peut quand même pas
ignorer cela bon sens il ya 10 millions
de gens qui frise le seuil de pauvreté
enfin donc on peut pas dire le l'avenir
de l'agriculture celle haut de gamme et
en imaginant tout régler enfin voila je
voulais terminer en vous disant que le
maître mot christiane ne l'a martelé la
raison c'est la diversité c'est la
diversité diversité de l'alimentation
diversité de la distribution du commerce
les circuits courts bien évidemment à
côté des autres modèles la diversité des
modes de production la diversité
d'agriculture nous seront garants de
notre souveraineté par cette diversité
c'est la diversité qui nous rendra
garant de notre souveraineté
alors je dois vous dire que je préfère
le mot sécurité à celui de souveraineté
j'ai peur que le mot soit un peu
galvaudé et que pour certains on y voit
le repli et l'enfermement sur notre
agriculture française
voilà pourquoi je ne pourrais plus
souvent c'est qu'ils ont été
la diversité sera garante de notre santé
c'est la diversité alimentaire qui est
garante de la santé et de la
soutenabilité de notre agriculture
c'est comme ça qu'on aura le soutien de
notre société
c'est par cette belle diversité voilà
j'étais sans doute trop long mais encore
une fois bravo pour vos travaux
[Applaudissements]
mais toujours avec autant de passion ce
qui est agréable et et tu as raison sur
la sur la souveraineté moi je fais
attention aussi en utilisant le mot de
souveraineté y colle ou régaliens parce
que là c'est l'état qui décide ensuite
sur le reste et bien c'est la sécurité
c'est l'autonomie c'est tout ce que l'on
a découvert dans un autre domaine qui
est celui de la santé où cette crise
nous a révélé qu effectivement on s'est
rendu compte qu'on avait perdu notre
autonomie en matière de soins de
protection contre le contre les virus et
qu'on était dépendant de puissance
étrangère et donc effectivement il faut
être prudent on n'est pas dans une
logique
enfin administré effectivement pour
laisser cette compétitivité parce que
c'est ce qui fait l'amélioration et la
performance de l'agriculture
on va peut-être prendre des questions
des internautes parce que on les a un
peu laissé de côté on en a eu beaucoup
je sais pas qui 1 allez vas-y
effectivement on revient à ceux qui nous
suivent et nous avons une question de
françois d'annecy qui évoque des sujets
que philippe mongin a a évoqué sur la
montée en gamme l'accessibilité
notamment
alors je prends la question de françois
les consommateurs orientaux recherchent
de plus en plus de qualité
pardon je suis perdu dans mes oui aussi
donc je reprends les consommateurs
occidentaux recherchent de plus en plus
de qualité de bio et de produits frais
dans leur supermarché
al'inverse la croissance exponentielle
de la population mondiale risque de nous
obliger à revoir notre modèle de
production pour nourrir l'ensemble de la
planète alors n'est ce pas paradoxal et
comment s'adaptent les industriels pour
répondre à ces deux demandes opposé nous
y avons répondu un peu tous les trois
d'ailleurs
c'est vrai qu'a priori on pourrait dire
mais c'est pas compatible quoi tout ça
on peut pas faire les deux à la fois
mais messi messi
complètement enfin est-ce qu'on peut
avoir des doutes sur la capacité
exportatrice du grand bassin parisien en
maintenant le domaine des céréales
quand même une des plaines les plus
fertiles du monde une une organisation
une performance remarquable
on va pas demander à cette agriculture à
cette grande région à l'école
d'abandonner cette vocation pour se
consacrer au circuit tour même si autour
de la couronne parisienne
on peut recréer du circuit court et de
l'approvisionnement de nos grandes
agglomérations dans la ceinture
donc si l'agriculture elles peuvent
cohabiter sans difficulté mais vraiment
et dans un même village aujourd'hui il
ya un agriculteur bio il ya un
agriculteur que moi et mon frère qui
sommes sur les grandes productions et
donc sur livraisons port de metz pour
déboucher sur le nord de l'europe
et puis il ya un éleveur de viande qui
est en circuits courts et un autre qui
est livreur chez bigard et leur modèle
de production sont en train d'évoluer en
fonction en fonction de ses différents
clients qui n'ont pas les mêmes
exigences
donc moi je n'ai aucune crainte quant à
la cohabitation la coexistence de tous
ses modèles au contraire qu'il faut
entretenir vraiment de boubakeur de
bagneux alors que l'agriculture
française est l un des rares secteurs
exportateurs faisant la fierté de notre
pays
comment en est on arrivé là et moi je
rajoutera un point non seulement faisant
la fierté de notre pays mais faisant
aussi la carte de visite de notre paix
de nos pays parce que si on avait autant
de clients sur nos exportations c'est
parce que tout simplement comme vous
l'avez dit notre modèle était quelque
chose qui prend présentait pour ces
clients là le summum de la qualité donc
comme en un temps à arriver là et quels
sont les moyens à mettre en place pour
retrouver cette part de fierté
qui nous fait tant défaut aujourd'hui
c'est comme en étant égal à ccc
moi je crois que d'abord on a laissé
s'installer une espèce de 2,2 regard
complètement nostalgique et idéologique
sur l'agriculture alors entretenu par
les médias etc
mais pas seulement pas seulement par des
tas d'acteurs sans doute que on n'a pas
mesuré la force et que ça n'a fait que
grandir dans dans dans l' écoute de 2,2
de la société pour en arriver là où nous
en sommes c'est pour ça que je
souhaitais commencé mon intervention je
voulais même vous dire l'heure est grave
l'heure est grave parce que parce que
vraiment l'agriculture n'est plus traité
n'a plus été traité comme elle devrait
l'être et est du coup enfin combien
d'agriculture combien d'agriculteurs
découragez pas seulement pour des
questions de revenus pas seulement pour
ces raisons là souvent pour ces raisons
là mais pas uniquement les agriculteurs
découragés par le traitement des
questions à l'école alors la semaine qui
a remplacé les salons l'agriculture
heureusement et merci christiane d'y
avoir contribué à améliorer un peu les
choses
on a remis un peu l'église au milieu du
village avec toutes ces émissions qui
font qu'on a pu entendre ces derniers
jours
mais d'où vient ton de doux parts et on
a cessé c'est quand même assez
incroyable pendant pendant un temps et
il n'est pas si lointain tous les
dimanches soir tous les dimanches soir
il y avait une une une émission de
démolition de tel ou tel produit
alimentaire on est passé des tomates ou
poisson etc
pardon
oui aussi mais rendez vous compte
comment voulez vous que nos concitoyens
c'est s'il retrouve avec tout ça si au
dessus de ça il n'ya pas une volonté
politique un discours politique fort qui
balaye tout ça d'un revers de main et
qu'ils disent
l'agriculture c'est une richesse de la
france c'est notre une de deux de nos
fleurons et et c'est ce qui nous permet
d'avoir encore autorité sur le dans les
négociations internationales grâce à
tout ce qu'elle est enfin bon sens
nicolas sarkozy au lendemain de la crise
de financière ouais bon le g20 qui a été
créée avait inscrit cette question à
l'ordre du jour à la demande de la
france et elle avait été retenue
on se repose pour moi c'est une victoire
extraordinaire
je me suis dit alors là vraiment avoir
réussi à inscrire la question agricole
au g20 on venait de connaître les
grandes fluctuations aussi des effets de
volatilité des émeutes
en effet dans cette période et on a dit
il faut poser la question agricole et la
france a été entendue
pourquoi parce que la france agricole
elle est reconnue dans le monde on ne
contestera pas de vouloir traiter de ces
questions
voilà moi je crois que il faut vraiment
reprendre tout ça avec force et fierté
fierté quelle fierté devrions-nous avoir
de notre agriculture française très bien
justement en parlant de fierté une
dernière question de frédéric de
bordeaux qui s'inquiètent de savoir
comment on va faire pour trouver des
jeunes pour s'investir dans le métier
d'agriculteur on voit de plus en plus de
d'urbain aller à la campagne reprendre
des fermes
donc comment attirer de nouveaux actifs
vers l'agriculture ce magnifique métier
christiane et a fort bien répondu je
crois d'abord qu'il faut renverser un
peu c'est ce ce discours ambiant
décourageant et c est dire que ce métier
fabuleux et que toutes les encore une
fois tout ce champ d'innovation qui
s'offre à nous présente des challenge
formidable va améliorer les conditions
de travail
on travaille sur beaucoup sur les
conditions d'amélioration du travail
notamment dans le monde de l'élevage etc
donc voilà d'abord avoir un discours
positif voyez je suis aussi président du
conseil d'administration d'un lycée
agricole
c'est une belle expérience aussi ça on
voit des jeunes motivés heureusement
mais ils ont tous
je fais ce constat depuis deux ou trois
ans un projet individuel c'est un peu
inquiétant quand même ils sont ils sont
tous dans d'andorre dans la déterminée à
dire moi je vais je vais vendre ce que
je produis tout seul je veux sortir de
10 circuits classiques etc
alors tant mieux parce que ça concourt
au développement de la diversité de de
l'innovation des circuits courts de la
vente directe etc mais mais ça ne peut
pas faire une puissance agricole tout ça
et c'est bien parce que les jeunes
sourds ne se retrouve pas dans ils ne
sentent pas le sens de la politique
agricole faut redonner du sens à la
politique agricole il faut que critique
enfin vraiment qu'ils perçoivent ce que
l'on veut faire de l'agriculture
française et il faut qu'ils soient
persuadés qu enfin moi je rêverais
d'avoir 20 ans vraiment j'en rêverai une
autre question que pensez vous du projet
de xavier niel justement sur cette école
d'agriculture qui va mettre en place
dans peu de temps avec des milliers de
jeunes formés chaque année sur le type
de la station f qui est formidable pour
les start up
qu'est ce que vous en pensez bah moi je
pense que d'abord on peut s'en féliciter
qu'il ya un intérêt porté et est une
volonté d'investir pour que les jeunes
s'intéressent se former et pourquoi pas
de vienne agriculteurs je suis comme
christiane je serais assez vigilants
quant aux objectifs et de formation aux
au modèle avec un s au pluriel qui
seront dispensés
promu faut être un peu vigilant là
dessus quand même je partage cette
réserve
c'est il faut faire attention à la
caricature et on a tous les risques de
la caricature et de l'opération de
communication alors en revanche si
effectivement on est capable et
l'énergie que tu évoquais bon moi j'ai
décroché cela mais je à chaque fois que
je suis en déplacement et que je peux
visité un lycée agricole je le fais et
les projets individuels tu as raison
c'est fabuleux de voir à la fois
l'imagination la détermination la force
de conviction de ces jeunes qui sont
animés par des projets donc ça c'est
quand même fabuleux faut d'abord
souligner ça mais après c'est toujours
en individuel effectivement tout la
logique or on voit bien que si on veut
peser sur le marché de l'exportation sur
l'alimentation mondiale sur la
production de masse sur les entrées de
gamme ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure il
ya besoin d'avoir une dimension qu'ils
soient qu'ils soient collectives et ça
on voit nos jeunes et on se dit en temps
et bon sens cette énergie si on est
capable de la concentrer c'est
formidable parce que c'est un levier
extraordinaire parce que il n'y a pas
toujours eu cette dynamique dans les
lycées agricoles d'avoir des jeunes qui
ont autant de projets puis autant envie
d'y aller aujourd'hui on le sent partout
mais il faut arriver à faire prendre la
machine et le point et c'est pour ça que
j'ai souhaité qu' on est aux
républicains au delà de toutes les les
autres questions qu'on a abordé sur la
sécurité sur l'immigration sur la santé
sur l'entreprise qu'on ait ce focus
alimentation et agriculture leurs
maîtres et tu l'a très bien dit sur le
devant de la scène politique moi j'y
crois vraiment beaucoup
c'est un enjeu qui et géostratégiques on
ne peut pas la france ne peut pas à
abandonner dire la place qui est la
sienne sur le marché de l'alimentation
mondiale
et puis sur son autonomie alimentaire
qui est aussi essentiel parce que la
balance
on l'évoquait tout à l'heure votre
balance aujourd'hui si on retire les
vins spiritueux la réalité c'est qu'on
est déficitaire
donc il ya ce défi à relever est celui
de peser sur la scène internationale
parce qu'on a attendu par tous que a
évoqué guy savoy notre savoir faire
partout dans le monde entier
on s'arrache que les chefs cuisiniers
français on s'arrache les oenologues
français on s'arrache les chefs de chez
les maîtres de chai partout on va
chercher des français pour faire
rayonner l'alimentation donc il faut
qu'on se mette à y croire à nouveau
et aujourd'hui je pense qu'il ya
vraiment une vraie perspective pour
porter un projet agricole en tout cas
c'est de cette manière dont on est on
est engagé moi je j'y mets tout
l'énergie qui est qui et qui est la
mienne parce que je suis convaincu de
cela et je sens qu'on a un moment où ça
peut à nouveau prendre parce qu'il ya ya
ya un intérêt donc faisant attention de
poètes dans les vieilles photos jaunies
ou dans la nostalgie de gens qui se
raconte des histoires bien souvent
qu'ils sont obligés d'inventer pour
pouvoir bien se la raconter parce qu'ils
l'ont pas vécue en réalité mais bon
faire des choses en tout cas il ya sept
belles perspectives en donner la parole
à philippe mais je voulais vraiment le
temps de te remercier pour à la fois ce
coup de gueule mais plein de
perspectives c'est à dire de dire mais
bon sang on a quand même deux
formidables choses à faire on a des
opportunités comme que comme jamais et
donc il ya un cap à passer
et est ce que l'on fait avec des là
aussi nos grands les grands groupes
agroalimentaires ils sont français
pourquoi ils sont français aujourd'hui
parce qu'il ya une activité de
production
le jour où il n'y a plus d'activité de
production agricole en france on perd le
levier de l'agroalimentaire il n'y a pas
dans le monde un seul exemple d'une
industrie agroalimentaire qui tiennent
lorsqu'il ya plus d'activités de
production
c'est ça la réalité notre notre notre
agriculture dernier point peut-être
philippe sur christiane l'a déjà évoqué
tout à l'heure mais
sur le
le carbone vrai que tu nous en dire un
mot parce que on voit aujourd'hui avec
les quotas carbone nos grandes
entreprises françaises qui qui achètent
des des quotas et qui investissent à
l'autre bout du monde ce qui est parfois
très bien mais il y à aussi à leurs
portes dès des possibilités énormes avec
est ce que font les agriculteurs au
quotidien russe
non mais je n'y a pas grand chose à
rajouter à ce que christiane a dit c'est
vraiment le sujet quoi d'abord c'est une
possibilité de démontrer de enfin oui de
prouver de prouver que l'agriculture est
une solution
c'est en participant à à 7 à cet échange
de carbone en montrant notre
contribution
effectivement c'est dommage de voir
certains groupes qui sont allés chercher
des solutions
à l'autre bout du monde alors que nous
en avons là alors quand même derrière ça
il reste le débat du prix du carbone si
vraiment là encore on veut bien on veut
mobiliser l'agriculture les agriculteurs
sur les couverts végétaux sur tout ce
qu'il faut faire
justement pour solutionner enfin plutôt
pour trouver des alternatives aux
pesticides
parce que je crois quand même pas
repousser ce débat d'un revers de main
les agriculteurs sont vraiment mobilisés
sur le sujet tout le monde a envie de
trouver des alternatives autant que
possible à la chimie de synthèse la
chimie de synthèse restera une des
solutions pour pour dédé et ed des oueds
et 1 passe des choses comme ça mais le
biocontrôle j'ai pas parlé du bio
contrôler les bio stimulant etc
on a des beaux projets là qui vont être
en alsace notamment à côté de colmar
ça y est il ya une vraie mobilisation
sur les sur les bus intrants et ce sera
voilà des alternatives qui vont
permettre donc je crois que vraiment si
on veut cette mobilisation des
agriculteurs il faut que la valorisation
de la tonne dépasse un peu les 20 euros
come on
on évoque souvent le faudrait que ça
apporte s'emballe 60 euros de l'hectare
quoi pour que vraiment les gens disent
bas et puisse aller vous quoi enfin ça
et puis et puis c c'est peut-être enfin
cesser la réponse à un débat qu'on n'a
jamais trop su trancher sur la
valorisation des services rendus des
services environnementaux rendus et ben
tiens là par le carbone on peut peut
être trouver la solution mais il faut
qu'on fasse monter un peu les prix mais
bon voilà
non messieurs sur le sur l'environnement
l'évoquent
lorsque j'ai conclure là dessus on
évoque souvent c'est l'agriculture et à
la fois parfois là la victime parfois la
cause est souvent la solution à dire
qu'on est dans les trois on est dans
l'étroit dans les trois registres et
avec une réponse que l'on peut apporter
aujourd'hui et c'est là que l'enjeu
agricole est déterminant il y a une
réponse alimentaire l'a longuement
évoqué aujourd'hui il y a une réponse
sur l'environnement avec l'énergie avec
tout ce qui est évoqué christiane très
bien tout à l'heure sur tout ce que l'on
peut faire aujourd'hui sur le plastique
biodégradable d'origine agricole on est
capable de se substituer à peu près tout
avec le
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique avec le piège à carbone
voilà l'agriculture peut répondre à tout
cela je voudrais adresser un dernier
message à nos auditeurs d'abord merci de
nous avoir suivis téléspectateurs nous
avoir suivis aussi longtemps c'est on va
être relayée sur les sur tous les
réseaux pendant pendant toute la semaine
donc merci à tous et à toutes
et je pense que ce débat alors on n'a
pas retrouvé nos 20 ans mais moi je les
ai retrouvés un peu quand même parce que
j'avais mon prédécesseur et mon
successeur au cndd jia j'ai retrouvé
michel edouard maintenant on s'est tous
un peu notabilisé mais on est tous
capables de beaucoup de passion et c'est
ce qui fait plaisir monde agricole est
vraiment merci à tous les trois merci à
guy savoy parce que vous avez tous les
3es et guy savoy en ouverture parler de
l'agriculture de l'alimentation avec
passion avec des perspectives
et puis en y croyant profondément et ça
ça nous fait ça nous fait chaud au coeur
et puis ça nous donne envie à nous de
prendre aussi nos responsabilités de
politique et de nous battre encore
davantage sur un secteur qui est au
combien ô combien stratégique
donc on va arrêter là pour aujourd'hui
on se retrouvera la prochaine fois on
sera sur la décentralisation services
publics fin sur un tout autre domaine
pour notre notre prochaine notre
prochaine convention et à bientôt et au
plaisir de vous retrouver